あ、こいつがノコノコだよ
プレイ台が入らない、新ホッケーゲーム
甲羅が浮くよ！！
プレイ台がなくても平面な場所ならどこでも遊べる！！
これ
マジやばくね？
これマジやばくね？
これあの、僕見つけた瞬間
「ヤベー」と思いました
ちょっと開けてみます
ボカーーン
これが...あの...あれ（俊敏な動き）
で、ここに本体ですな
ビリッ
ああぁぁん♡
こちらが甲羅
要するにこの甲羅が空気をこうやって出て〜
これをねぇ、こうやって
コツコツやるわけなんですけども
普通エアホッケーって
この床から空気が出てて
それでこれがちょっと浮いて
浮いたやつをこうやってできるんですけど
このノコノコエアホッケーはこの本体自身から空気が出ています
つまり、一般家庭でもできる
エアホッケーなんですよ、これ
電池入れてみます
あ”あ”あ”ぁ”ぁ”
ドライバーヤダニーだわ
ううんっ
ポンッ
（信長没落）
あら
なんやかんやでドアライバーって大切ですよ
さ〜て、入れてみるぞよ
おっけー
入れて
締め直すと...おっけー
わいが知りたいのは
そもそもこれがどれくらい
浮くかっていうとこですね〜
ちょってオンにしてみます
はい
ブイィィィィィィィィン
おぉ、おぉ、おぉ、おぉ
おぉ！おぉ！！おぉ！！！おぉ！！！！
おぉ〜すごい、すごい
もう、置くとどんな机でも平面状だったら
これでこうやって、もうエアホッケーができるという仕組みになっております
（荒ぶるノコノコ）
あ”あ”あ”ぁ”ぁ”
これ....
使えるな
これ確か見つけたの去年のクリスマスぐらいだったんですけども
頑張ってこれたくさん集めました
全然お店に売ってなくて〜
ほんとに、もうね
いろんなお店に行った
静岡のお店、東京のお店
色々見たんですけど
全然売ってなくて
Amazonを使い
ネットショッピングを使い
もうなんとか全力を尽くして
これだけ集めました
はい
ボカーーーン
（壁の崩れ落ちる音）
これ以上は無理だった
これ以上は無理だったぁ〜
Amazonとかも
なんかお一人様１０個までとか、個数制限かかってて
なに？そんなレアなの？
とか思いながらちょっと買ったんですけど
２５個集めるのにかなり苦労しました
今回はこれを使って
もう浮くじゃないですか、この甲羅が
この甲羅から空気が出て、浮くということは
これをたくさん集めれば
いや...だってうu...浮くじゃん！？
ブィィィィィィィン
ほら！！
これだけたくさんの甲羅があれば
それの上にこう僕が乗ると
ひょっとしたら浮けるんじゃないかと思いまして
でもあn...
思ったより弱かったなぁ...
やることに意味があります
もう、浮けなかったら浮けなかったでもういいんですよ
失敗したら失敗したで、僕もたくさんのエアーホッケーで遊びますよ
では
セッティング！！！！！！
＜はじめの攻撃＞
＜敵は怯んで動けない＞
＜はじめんが楽しそうに笑っている＞
＜敵の逆襲＞
（スイカバー）
＜会心の一撃＞
メガァァァァァァァァァァァ
ああああああぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
えええ！？あぶねぇ、あぶねぇ、あぶねぇ
はい、というわけで甲羅全部に電池を入れました
えっと、この大量の打つ部分と
甲羅２５個と
ノコノコエアホッケーのシールが
出てきました
シールは...使わないな
一回全部電源つけてみましょう
＜産声を上げ出す２５個の甲羅ブラザーズ＞
うるせぇぇぇぇ
はい、一応全部これで
あ”あ”ぁ”ぁ”一人落ちた！！
一応これで全部電源は入ってまーす
＜自由に動き回る２５個の甲羅ブラザーズ＞
待って、待って、待って
待って、待って、ほんと、待って、待って
動くなよ、動くなよ
はい、というわけでこれからこの上に一枚あの、板を置きます
とりあえず、まず板を置いて動くかどうかですね
ちょっとやってみましょう
３・２・１
というわけで
正直もうねぇ
１個目の電気つけた瞬間
もう無理ってわかってました
パワー不足です
まぁ
乗れないっすわ
逆に何なら乗れるんだろう
こういう薄い紙っぺらとかなら乗れるのかねぇ
乗せてみます
オォォイ！！！
＜楽しくエアーホッケー＞
おほっほっほっほっほっほっ
＜はじめの一撃＞
＜返り討ち＞
いつものED
(いて)